by the power of castle hate school i am
how long carly
h-a-r-l-e-y if you don't know how to
spell it boy oh boy do we have another
absolute biggity bang show for you
tonight is it tonight i don't know maybe
you're watching it tonight maybe it's
the morning maybe it's the middle of the
day i have no idea so all i can do is
speculate and say guess what this show's
good whenever you watch it alright let's
hone in on that fact okay this is not a
a good morning america type of situation
where once you don't watch it in the
morning it doesn't age well okay this
podcast is meant to be evergreen you can
watch episodes in the middle of the
night put it on while you sleep you'll
probably learn something by osmosis so
speaking of the middle of the night boy
oh boy sup full sup with me well a bunch
of stuff it's ironic that last week i
was telling you about how dangerous it
is to not get enough sleep and here i am
running on three hours of sleep because
guess what i wanted to go to a film
festival last night in santa barbara
mark what are you doing in santa barbara
in the middle of the night at a film
festival
well my boy nick ritchie who you guys
know if you've been watching the podcast
because he came on the podcast to talk
about the film that was premiering at
the santa barbara international film
festival called 1800 hot night
it in fact was dope
af
it in fact was a fantastic experience it
just put me in a position where i'm like
uh you know it starts at uh 8 40. it
gets out when you're at a film festival
it's like you just go like all right
movie's over bye-bye driving home
you got friends there you're doing the q
a you're getting drinks afterwards
you're talking everyone involved you're
networking you're doing all the things
and i don't begrudge that i think that's
what you need to do to fully that's like
a once in a lifetime experience because
that is the world premiere of 1 800 hot
night quick movie review
it's great you guys should really see it
when it comes out uh 1 800 hot night
n-i-t-e is how it's spelled um
it's a coming-of-age drama about
these three young men
who
it's loosely based on nick's upbringing
so
like these are these are lower middle
class kids who
uh the main character is dealing with a
parent being arrested and him like
running from child protective services
over the course of a night but it kind
of that's the catalyst for this
adventure that they have
and i'll leave it at that it's
phenomenal my friend cameron who i went
with
who
is also an actor and you know he's well
steeped in entertainment so this isn't
just some random person saying this he
said that was way better than i ever
could have imagined and i'd read the
scripts and set him up to be like this
script's really good
uh but the movie did take it above and
beyond met some cool
uh people there including let's just
let's just cut to the chase because last
night i met my idol
uh his name is javon walton you probably
know him as ashtray from euphoria
legitimately i saw this kid and i was
like oh my god i gotta get a picture of
you did i get a picture of mike tyson
when i saw him in person no did i get a
picture with ashtray of course i did
because i'm a bigger fan of ashtray than
i am of mike tyson no knock on mike
tyson but you also don't seem like
somebody that i'd want to sit down and
have a conversation with however
ashtray was a very sweet guy we talked
about euphoria because i just had to say
yo this is one of the best tv shows of
all time perhaps my favorite tv show of
all time
it's open for discussion and especially
the last few episodes of the season
including the season finale with the
play within the screenplay within the tv
show
it's just absolutely mind-blowing how
well it was done
no spoilers but
uh ashtray also has an amazing final
episode
of season two and if you haven't watched
it i encourage you to if you're into
high level art
in tv if you don't like that if you like
crappy stuff if you like junk food
entertainment then don't watch it
but if you want to challenge yourself
intellectually and artistically as a
consumer
watch euphoria and you guys probably
have already watched it already because
you're a sophisticated audience
i wanted to give a quick shout out to
the other well first of all if you
scroll down for a second i texted that
picture to my the group text with
brandon chappelle and other people that
he tours with the bicho ass tour group
text
i said met my idol last night brendan
said dream bigger huh
brandon's always good for bringing you
back to reality um
i wanted to give a shout out to some of
the young actors the three main leads
dallas young beast milan bradford beast
garrison machado beast
this is a picture with garrison here
he came up to me and said hey love the
podcast i said oh my god me you guys
like me it actually was surprising
because i'm like oh i didn't think about
a 15 year old actually watching my
podcast so mentally i scanned all the
episodes like
how much inappropriate [ __ ] have you no
but i really stand by it's not like
we're sitting here you know i'm
advocating if anything i would want to
hear a lot of the stuff that i'm
discussing on the podcast as a 15 year
old um i believe garrison works out he
looks like you know for a 15 year old
kid he's got some pretty good muscular
development garrison if you're watching
this let's work out some time okay
it was cool meeting you you're super
talented and the three young leads
they're all very different um
i don't know what else garrison and
mylon have done but i know dallas for
example is on cobra kai and these guys
are all just
they've got it they're future stars they
can you know go do whatever they want i
think there's going to be lots of
opportunities for them they nailed it in
the lead of an independent film
and you know the
program i don't know if he was a program
director or just a guy who worked at the
film festival but he was like
specifically this film is
really stood out to us he's like i
couldn't wait to see this this is like
just one of our favorites here blah blah
and i believe it you know made for 200
000 bucks and what they did for that
amount of money is is absolutely
phenomenal
so what else is going on in my life well
i uh as you guys know i've been blasting
trent winstral master on and a little
bit of test you know just a little drip
drop a test but
for this two week film music video
preparation
mini cycle that i'm doing just to test
the limits of how much gear can i take
in 12 days without dying um but
in the middle of that i got an offer
that i couldn't refuse which was isaiah
texted me saying hey are you down to do
a chick-fil-a eating challenge with noel
now she he didn't actually say
chick-fil-a he said just like an eating
challenge video like ordering the whole
menu or something along those lines of
you know we're gonna eat a lot of food
so it's like i guess i guess i could do
that and
i wanted to take this opportunity to
talk about diet a little bit um because
like
i want to be open when i'm hypocritical
or not doing the things that i'm
preaching to you and
go into like the reasons that you know
it might have been last week when i shot
the podcast yeah i hit up mcdonald's
it's like
and
like when i go to mcdonald's like i'm
getting 20 bucks worth of stuff you know
what i mean i'm getting i got a spicy
chicken sandwich mcnuggets a mcflurry uh
apple the blueberry pie
um
a big mac and i ate all that and i was
like i could do that again you know it's
a lot of food but it wasn't like i
almost was like i wanted to make myself
sick so that i wouldn't want to do it
again but then that doesn't really
happen and also i just wanted to address
something that's a flawed mentality when
it comes to food or drugs or whatever
this idea that like i'm just suddenly
going gonna get enough of this binge
addiction thing that i have you know
it's like i'm just gonna keep doing
cocaine until i'm sick of it well turns
out it doesn't work that way you're just
gonna
it's like uh if you're a kid and you get
caught smoking cigarettes and like
you're gonna smoke a whole carton yeah
and you're like well now i love
cigarettes right it's like now i'm
addicted to that and i've actually
watched my friends try to do that like
smoking up cigarettes to the point where
like they were puking like that was
their big idea and this is a friend of
mine
who who did struggle legitimately with
uh nicotine and cigarette addiction but
the only thing that worked was like
um
chantix
[ __ ] chantix
can they photoshop the cigarette out of
my mouth if you haven't seen that uh
what's the dude's name kyle something
kyle dunnigan kyle.com so good he's so
good the uh
the the ray liotta shantix commercial
parody is just one of the best things on
the internet if you haven't seen that so
that was the only thing we're from
remember he talked about going to like
hypnosis and it didn't work and he was
like aware of it as this guy's like he's
like i can hear the one-on-one freeway
in the background i'm in this dude's
basement like in a recliner it's super
awkward he's walking me through this
thing and i'm just like no certain
people are susceptible to hypnosis and
others aren't
but
let's say he was not susceptible
whatsoever so the awkwardness of this
experience that you also get a audio
tape of afterwards was just tremendous
and i got to witness him doing this like
i'm going to smoke a carton of
cigarettes until i puke and it didn't
work
and they were also like
they they had this vase that they put
all the cigarette butts in
like over time so it's like he was like
smelling it and putting his face in it
to like reinforce but it's like it just
doesn't work that way not that i'm aware
of and they tried it and didn't do it
maybe it works for some people but this
notion just to bring it back to the
mcdonald's it's like well i'm going to
have this last hurrah at some point you
just have to say this still seems good
to me and i just have to stop so i was
in a habit of eating more fast food than
normal and that's okay because like
as you're putting on muscle like it's
not the worst thing in the world to like
eat a bunch of calories and you have
protein in there and you get extra carbs
it's not the best thing in the world but
like you know it can actually help you
put on some muscle like
much more so than not eating in a
caloric surplus so um i have been
putting on muscle but also fat and for
reasons like that but the day after that
i ate
i made another impulse decision to go to
in and out and had a three by three
animal style fries and a shake
ironically that fills me up a lot more i
don't know if you've ever had like with
in and out like
having like a double double or so it's
more filling than mcdonald's i don't
know what it is but um you know but i
also hate to be like internet's so good
it's like the best quality like it's
still fast food but yes it is higher
quality so
now like after that i'm like all right i
need to stop eating like 3 000 calorie
fast food meals uh you know and get back
and see if i'm actually gonna you know
look decent and not puffy and bloated on
camera next week i need to stop
so i'm like all right hard stop we're
gonna end this right now this ends right
now have you seen barry
right now and
then isaiah hits me up like hey want to
do it ten thousand calories i'm like i
guess you know
every time i went out they pulled me
back in but
um
it was an interesting fun little because
you know i just really like isaiah noel
they're fun people and we had a lot of
fun ordering the whole chick-fil-a menu
go watch that video if you want i
actually was surprised to see that in
without shoes but with clothes on i
weighed like 260 to start with that's
the most i've ever weighed
am i the most jacked i've ever been
maybe
yeah i don't know if i'm the most strong
i've ever been but i'm certainly i weigh
the most and i have a size in certain
areas
that
is just unprecedented
not in my penis that's basically the
same you know but like ironically you
get bigger everywhere else it looks
smaller by proportion and so
you know that's why i'm trying to lean
out yeah
question do skinny guys have bigger
[ __ ] or is it just an optical illusion
i'm willing to take the chance yeah
maybe a little bit of both
um
okay and
i just wanted to say like so you know i
eat this fast food
and
it's okay to do that just know that like
you're never gonna get sick of it if
something tastes good it's probably
gonna taste good tomorrow and fat and
sugar are addicting so at some point you
just need to pull the plug and i'm gonna
bring it back
there is a cake out there the ninja
turtle cake that i just walked by
and it looks so good like it's a high
quality cake should we go get it should
we go okay no what i did was we could go
bring it in yeah if you bring it in i
want to show it on camera cause i walk
by and i'm like i want to take a piece
so bad right now but you know what i did
instead i sniffed it and walked away oh
yeah like a pair of panties um
what who does that i don't do i'm just
saying in theory that's what somebody
who's really creepy with panties would
do because i'm a food creep
oh here we go dude and this is one of
those like you know this isn't like a
shitty safeway cake like you can tell
like the sponginess and
this is an actual i mean it looks to be
and smells like an actual high quality
ninja turtle cake
okay before i drop this all over myself
and
ruin the episode okay you know let's
just jump into a liver king meme of the
week because he's our boy dude can we
get this video going
a little instagram okay i did it i
licked my fingers and i'm hooked
so
he's here in the best bushman
i don't know if he's he's like is he
talking or is he just like
doing a parody of what white people
think african bushmen speak like you
know
i don't know and that's enough for me to
even speculate on because that's
obviously racist so
i wanted to show this one because he's
with these
is this part of like this new york like
where is he in the world where in the
world is liver king
if you know carmen san diego you know
what i'm talking about you're also 40
years old like me now what i thought was
fun and ironic about this video thank
you chris
wipe the ninja turtle frosting off my
face what i thought was funny about this
video is
like his whole thing is like live like
an ancestor
live like a bushman basically and you'll
look like this and he's next to this
dude who looks nothing like him like
obviously this dude is like you know not
enhanced and probably doesn't lift
weights but the contrast couldn't be
more uh stupendous as far as
these dudes do not and they look great
like they actually look i think if you
did live you know like an ancestral
tribe and they tend to be really lean
because you know if you're not eating a
bunch of processed food and
wolfing down two three by threes with
animal fries yeah you know you're
probably gonna stay at a healthy body
weight but the contrast between him and
a guy who preaches this ancestral
lifestyle couldn't be more distinct
let's go on to the liver king meme right
below there
this first one is
they took the picture of liver king
throwing that spear
and then this huge buff
anime cartoon woman is going does my
little burnt nugget man need his d-ball
he's saying babe help and the d belt d
ball's up at the top shelf of the uh the
supermarket
um aisle
because he's short get it
when your children i just love this
format too what is this like is it pon
wars i've never seen them but it's like
a pawn shop show right when your
children are sick of liver and just beg
you for normal food like a cheeseburger
liver king chimes in it says best i can
do is testicles
okay and we got a hella mark harley meme
of the week
my man d rabone coming through oh once
again
this is that classic spider-man format
tell me the truth i'm ready to hear it
and spider-man goes trolls and harley's
comments are insecure closeted gay men
oh but it's so true and i always say it
too but it's like you know and i want to
go into the hater the weak stuff a
little bit more
question of the day am i on kratom right
now well yes in fact i am and i continue
to be impressed with the effects of
kratom on my brain piece all right
i'm using it like my limitless pill i
feel like it's it's a legitimate
nootropic that i use for a little bit of
stimulation a little bit of brain
enhancement that helps get me in the
mood to speak into a microphone for an
hour at a time and not just as a stumble
over my words all right
it is a fantastic focused product and
again with happy hippo specifically i'm
not just plugging kratom in general
these are high quality products that you
can trust you can get
pills you can get powder you can get
these little shots that i really love
that gives you a really good dose
in a very convenient fashion so if you
guys are into trying this stuff i want
you to check it out tell me what you
think of it because it's going to be an
ongoing discussion as i continue to find
my perfect dose of kratom check out
happyhippo herbals.com and use promo
code thickboy for 20 off for any order
i am genuinely interested to hear what
you guys think about the product because
i'm loving it and i want you guys to
love it as well it's not just about the
haters it's about the philosophy behind
it so i will go into that and and kind
of go into like you know is every guide
commenting on my page they closeted gay
men i don't know i think they're
somewhere on that spectrum and it's
indicative of this like lashing out
behavior that is sort of mirrored by
you're concealing something and
something's wrong over here like there's
pressure and stress over here that kind
of makes this pop out over here that's
the way i conceptualized it one of those
things is if you're in the closet and
you're thinking about nobody finding out
about your sexuality or like this one
dude a few weeks ago was like
cuck-cuck-cuck like calling me a [ __ ] 18
times and it's like
it seems like you're thinking about
cuckle drew quite a bit you know if
every comment on my page is about
cucking
maybe that's something you're into i
don't know i've never mentioned the word
on my page
nor is there any evidence publicly
available that i'm a cuck
so
not sure we're getting that from also d
raven came through with this meme of
me and chappelle
in the classic pulp fiction scene i love
this like the dude just surprises me
every time i'm like
you know so it's me as john travolta
and uh
chappelle as
you know morgan freeman no just what
that's
that's racist samuel jackson
you read the bible brett that is one of
my favorite scenes of all time and i saw
that as a kid walked into the theater
when i was there to see another movie
and saw that scene and i was like oh my
god
traumatized in a good way because i
wanted to go back and see it but it was
like the most interesting film scene i'd
seen in my life as an 11 year old all
right we got a hater of the week runner
up
this guy comments a lot of people have
been [ __ ] on me like it's always
funny i'm like dude
something happening like people will
just come like right away i try to
respond to people who comment on uh the
youtube page here and again if you have
any questions you have any comments i do
want to interact with you here it's also
funny when like as soon as the episode
drops like my haters do have alerts on
because it's like
the comments up front will be
sort of at least this week very loaded
with like just hateful crap like this i
lasted five seconds watching this trash
why would someone actively work to set
the bar so low and i said i only lasted
four seconds with your mom
heads up you got a new little brother on
the way bless up fam
pray and emoji
um i just like having little fun
comments like that because it's just so
easy and it's like you know what was the
first five seconds of my podcast me
saying
i'm hella mark harley like you're
listening to a podcast and he's like
this is garbage so it's always funny
because
with the haters you know you're
commenting on something that's an hour
long so like either you admit that you
stayed and watched the entire hour and
have some sort of substantive critique
or you're saying
i didn't watch any of it but it sucks
oh
a little bit of a trap there
okay this week i wanted to go i'll just
set it up real quick
because i feel like my response to this
could be confused for
defensiveness and it even makes me think
about somebody else like
the criticisms were about my legs of all
things which is just it's hilarious to
me because growing up
people would always like be shocked at
how big my legs are compared to the rest
of my body i'd always have this response
of like you know like they see my quads
for the first time and i'm not bragging
it's like i didn't like that i didn't
like like thinking that my legs were
disproportionately big but it was like
my whole life this you know my whole
life people have been making fun of my
lips like especially growing up like as
being too big or whatever and then like
now i'm in my 30s and guys are like you
have lip fillers it's like no i didn't
choose to look like this you know you're
getting it the opposite of what would be
going on if anything i'd have them
reduced you know as as a extension of an
insecurity so
where do my insecurities lie
not in having legs that are too small
like i and i have insecurities as
everybody does i don't feel like i need
to you know
go into them or like scan my brain right
now if they come up
i'll talk about them
but
you know one of my insecurities for
example is asymmetry like left right
asymmetry from like my shoulder injury
like that bothers me a ton
the idea that i would have skinny legs
is like the million thing like it just
wouldn't even exist it's not even on the
list so some girl came to my page it was
like don't forget leg day i didn't
follow me
you know i'd never commented and i was
like have you seen my legs
um and then she said yeah what is your
leg day trying to learn and i'm like
kind of seems like you were telling me
to not skip leg day
and then she says
that was until i saw your legs in the
495 dead lift which is like a you know
my recent video doing 4.95 for nine not
recent but like the most recent dead
lifting videos please share now i didn't
respond to her because i'm like
she turned it around and i appreciate
that that she came to me and said i want
advice from you but if you have the
energy of going to somebody's page and
it is like it's in the big scheme of
things obviously it's very innocent but
i just don't endorse it i don't endorse
going to people's pages and like being
like your boobs are too small
you know you're not tall enough
like you're ugly it's like what that
doesn't need to be said
and
if you're going to make a comment like
about somebody's physique at least make
it accurate so it's like yeah i don't
have small legs and then you got mud on
your face like oh well i then i looked
at a video
and anyway the next guy manning
underscore 22 who doesn't have any posts
but he has this
you know a picture of his physique in
his little
avatar here
obviously nothing impressive and i think
i even saw on his page he's like 20
years old which makes sense like a lot
of these guys i'm like i can tell you
are a man
who's
18 to 22 and you're confused about how
to behave on the internet you think this
is cool or something like that so he
says leg day i said oh i need to do leg
day because my legs are skinny and he
says literally
[ __ ] yes
and i said thank you for making yourself
look like a [ __ ] idiot publicly and i
went into it more with him but like i
posted about it and i guess i just had a
lesson of like
if i'm ever doing stuff like this to
other people check me into rehab because
obviously i'm on drugs um you know or
put a bullet in my head or check me
somehow because
this energy of like going to strangers
pages to critique their body and then
not even doing it in an accurate way is
just mind-blowing to me why would you do
that don't do that if you have that
instinct
write it down on a piece of paper and
throw it away because you're just off
track in some major way and
i'll say this going into
explaining myself or posting it because
like any time i post haters
for me it's a way to it's like i post it
and then i let it go i don't think about
it after that unless i'm going back to
like oh what's my head of the week then
i think about like i don't remember the
guy's name i don't remember what he
looks like it doesn't actually stick
with me because it's kind of like
releasing it now if blocking that person
is that thing for you or ignoring them
good
but people will come to me and be like
you should really block the um or ignore
them or do like people telling i hate
people telling me what to do when it's
like do you understand what i'm doing no
so
my process to inform people like hey
this is what i'm going through and i can
still say resilient and still stay
positive and still kind of like call
people out and it honestly doesn't
bother me like if you could hook me up
to some sort of heart rate monitor or
detect my stress levels it happens so
much that my responses are not born out
of stress or
being agitated and maybe it's a little
bit exciting to go back and forth with
somebody but like
i'm not like
getting angry getting really stressed
getting really defensive and i don't
know if that comes across or not i just
have this promise to you that you know
things are
okay in my mind when i respond to these
haters and it's not eating away at me
it's a demonstration it's like
exhibitionism for me and
i just want to instruct people like this
is one way to deal with it if you want
to make it fun make it public show other
people release it take away the power of
this person trying to sort of like
criticize you one-on-one and like let
everyone in on the joke that like this
person
went to a man's page who has 30-inch
thighs and said your legs are too small
right it's just like uh yeah
i use the example of it's like me you
know telling this guy who's white like
you're saudi arabian
no i'm not you have three hands no i
don't like what you know are you
but then but then he doubles down or i
double down like huh that's why you're
so defensive like no it's not being
defensive like i'm just saying i don't
have three hands i have two hands can
you see that like but these people
always want to double and double down
and i try to have
a conversation with them too maybe you
can do this as well i try to like
converse and engage because then you get
to see other forms of their thinking
right if you ask them like hey do you
think because he kept
referring to me being like soft
or weak or whatever and i'm like do you
think that engaging with people in this
way on the internet makes you look tough
or hard and you wouldn't answer that but
these are basic questions where it's
like so if you're accusing me of
appearing like this because i'm behaving
a certain way do you think you're coming
across as the opposite of that
honestly because
for most people
they're not going to be able to answer
that honestly if they were they'd have
to change their mind so i like you you
know setting up rhetorical traps like
that where it's like if you think i'm
weak for responding to do you think
you're strong for
engaging with me another man who you
don't know
critiquing his physical appearance on
the internet
hello chef harley
once again
some things that i've been messing
around with first of all
casey just blew my mind with a new
flavor of premier protein shake can we
get it on camera chocolate peanut butter
it tastes like a melted down pb cup and
your boy loves yeah
they're so good like every and the i
just so i went to costco they didn't
have the flavors they usually get but i
do like the vanilla vanilla is
exceptional it's like a vanilla ice
cream flavor what i've been doing oh
i'm gonna run off for a second all right
there goes mark i'll hold down the fort
um don't you hate when people are mean
to you um on the internet i'm always
like hey quit it all right mark's back
hey stop being mean on the internet
haters okay
this stuff right here
these are great because i find myself
like i like coffee i make it in the
morning but this is like
sort of idiot-proof like you don't have
to grind the beans or do anything and
it's actually so fine it's so finely
grounded that whatever they do to
micronize it like you don't actually
have to have hot water either you can
just put it in cold water so you can mix
one of these packets this is like a cup
of coffee so i'll put like two to make
it a strong cup of coffee like a double
string cup of coffee um or a double shot
of espresso
into a vanilla shake with some ice and
mix it up and it's like
it's amazing it tastes like a latte
right because it's like oh you got the
vanilla you got the coffee flavor
and instead of just drinking
like the milk aspect of it for the
calories you get 30 grams of protein so
i've been starting my day with this it's
just a super simple hack
another thing that you can do is uh
i've always been a big oatmeal guy for
when i'm cutting because it like it's a
good carb that fills you up and also
puts this cap on like
if i have cereal i'm gonna eat it more
even it's magic spoon but like you know
the hack of magic smoothies like well
you could eat the whole box oh no you
just ate 80 grams of protein
um not the worst thing but you did just
spend seven bucks you know because
that's how much of a box of their cereal
costs so
with oatmeal though if you prepare it on
the stovetop it takes a few minutes but
i'm less likely to then do it again even
though it tastes good i put a little
splenden there i do the old-fashioned
oats i like the consistency i put a cup
of
this three berry combination you can get
it at
costco that's blueberries blackberries
and raspberries tastes amazing put it in
while it's still cooking so it melts it
a little bit you get some of that juice
you swirl it up put some splenda in
there and then guess what you put this
is p e signs always send me these i need
to get more of it but this will make it
so your cup of oatmeal plus this is 25
grams of protein
tastes great
um the oatmeal cup plus the blueberries
and
raspberries and blackberries it's like
76 grams of carbs so that's a good like
pre-workout you know you could eat that
as a breakfast to start your day
normally again it's probably the upper
limit of carbs i'd eat in a meal if i'm
on a moderate
carb diet but oatmeal fills you up and
you're less likely to be like oh i'm
gonna get another serving because it
isn't there because you didn't make it
and uh you don't want to spend 10
minutes cooking more oatmeal okay bro
sands academy
is the next segment boy oh boy
i speaking of noel earlier oh and by the
way
can we scroll up for a second is there a
that video of
no you know what it's down a little bit
i just wanted to say this with the
chick-fil-a stuff it's under there there
we go
oh no
it's a mcchicken nugget eating
chick-fil-a sauce
somebody stopped me
and then he's like convulsing on the
ground so that just took me this guy's
like i think he could say anything with
that face and i'd laugh
now is he morbidly obese yes
uh you know is this his after shot yes
after eating that chicken nugget
injected with tren does he look like
that of course but i just wanted to
bring that back because i'm going to be
talking about noel again
um
i watched the video after i saw noel's
vlog with her i saw another video where
she's dead lifting and
she had a common problem that people
have where their hips shoot up when
you're starting the deadlift
and
i've had that happen many people have
when you start to go heavy like you your
hips shoot up
and people go i don't know what the deal
is whatever it looks bad you know it's
wrong but like how do you fix it and
from my perspective it's about creating
tightness in your upper back because
if you can
keep your
scapula engaged if you can keep your
traps flexed if you can keep your lats
packed quote unquote which is like you
flex them and bring them down here if
you can keep your upper upper back
muscles engaged at the start of the lift
you can't
uh have a cat-back or your hips really
can't rise because in order for your
hips to rise
you have to like change the angle your
arms actually have to come away from
your body
uh in order for your hips to rise
because you're like this and your arms
are here so for your hips to rise first
you see that your lats have to
uh stretch out even if it's just
slightly and your or your traps have to
go from here to here in order to have a
round cat-back so if you can work on
basically getting that bar off the floor
like with your upper back it's almost
like start in a deadlift position and
shrug it off the ground if you can do
that then you can deadlift the weight
and if you can think about that as an
individual cue and then turn that into a
simultaneous cue that you can like
pull with your scapula your traps your
lats
as you engage and push into the floor
then you'll never have that problem so
that's just a quick little thing that
most people struggle with especially
when they're starting to deadlift and
they go a little bit heavier you you hit
your upper limit but you can fix it by
consciously thinking about your upper
back engagement and shrugging it off the
floor
so to speak
and is there anything else i wanted to
talk about maybe maybe not
um
help i'm on steroids
i'm on stand right
now
i had a couple conversations recently
with a guy named warren who's a
filmmaker who i saw last night and also
chin our beloved chin who produces the
fighter and the kid and the shop show
and some other stuff
you know he's uh he was recently voted
best asian podcast producer
on the internet so we have a lot of
award-winning
podcast producers here in the thick boys
studio
one of the things he told me recently
because he was looking into trt and a
lot of people go to these clinics and
they just want to get the steroids you
know they just want to get on the
testosterones they're like man i don't
need the other stuff but what they will
offer to you first is
hey do you want to try hcg in clomid
that's basically a way of kickstarting
your own nuts okay
now does it work it in fact does
he said i forget what his starting point
was maybe like two or three hundred
nanograms per deciliter but he got up to
this like high end of the reference rage
over a thousand from what i remember him
saying nanograms per deciliter just
using clomid so if you're in a position
where you feel like your test is low and
you want to try to fix it
without injecting
testosterone directly into your body
first use that and i had a conversation
with a friend of mine warren
who was asking about the same thing and
i don't think he was super excited to
start doing trt but he is in his mid 40s
and
you know had the symptoms of low
testosterone is also just
there's kind of this cycle that happens
that you know it's not necessarily just
like
having low testosterone doesn't cause
this but like let's say you're sitting
all day let's say you're inside because
he's a filmmaker and he's been like
editing this
uh tiger documentary that he shot all
this footage in india and like it's like
been an obsession for years this project
and he's like let himself go you know
according to him and
these things all compound if you're
sitting if you're not lifting if you're
getting older if you're not getting
sunlight
all these things kind of
they they conspire together to make you
kind of feel like [ __ ] now
just doing testosterone could bust you
out of that right but it also could just
be like getting back to the gym
um you know or just going on walks
getting sunlight like not sitting as
much just being more active um all these
things because you know it's also like
low sex drive okay all these things
could work and i saw you could boost
your testosterone just from lifting
heavy things we have this conversation
about like how to change your momentum
as many of my conversations it's not
about like giving me the perfect program
or doing this it's about like i'm here
and like my momentum is going in this
way i'm here and i'm eating mcdonald's
and in and out and chick-fil-a every day
how do i switch that how do i walk past
the cake
in the middle of the studio
and for those kinds of people who don't
necessarily want to commit to trt for
the rest of your life you can use hcg
and clomid get your own natural test
going and potentially put yourself in
that high reference range for quite a
long time and when it wears off you can
do it again but it's also something that
people need to use i'm always shocked by
the amount of people that don't know the
basics about post cycle therapy
you should use that if it's available to
you if you know where to get it i go to
lralabs.com but there's also like
peptide pros all these like if you look
up peptides or google hcg or clomid you
can get this stuff online in this kind
of
market like gray area where you don't
need to go on the dark whip to order it
but also you need to click the box that
said i'm experimenting with this on my
rap rat and it's not for human
consumption
so
like literally you know as long as long
as you click that box it says you're not
going to ingest this as a human you can
buy all sorts of things online
and but like it works and if you if you
don't want to commit to injecting
yourself once or twice a week because a
lot of people are reversed to that and i
get it because it's annoying as [ __ ] i'm
injecting myself two to three times a
day now and it's just annoying you know
because i'm using
uh 100 milligrams of tran a day and also
one to 200 milligrams of masteron
and those are all hundred milligram
shots so i have to like inject here
inject here inject here take 200
milligrams of wind straw until my liver
dries up and crumbles and
blows away in the wind
but you know speaking of that because
that is part of
the help i'm on steroids that i wanted
to talk about
don't try this at home don't take that
much trend or that much wind straw like
what kind of [ __ ] would take 200
milligrams of winstrol a day i don't
know but i'm experimenting with this
upper limit stuff for a very short
amount of time
believing that it will be safe for me in
the short term or at least that i'm not
going to die of a heart attack and i
want to be able to report back to you
like hey
i took a walk in the wild side i know
what 700 milligrams of trend a week
feels like and i will report it now
which is the difference between that and
for instance neanderlon which is less
androgenic than tests so i was taking an
angelo alone for a while because it's
less androgenic
you feel less of that
andronergic signaling that's just this
fight-or-flight response you feel less
aggressive perhaps less
desirous to work out like i'd find
myself walking into the gym and doing
this
like i just don't want to be here i'm
making myself do it and i think that's a
good attitude to have is just do it
anyway but when you're on trend and
you're on a strong androgen
you're excited you know like i'm running
on three hours of sleep probably less
because i woke up multiple times
and you kind of it puts you in that
hypomanic state i wouldn't recommend
doing that for very long because part of
it is like anything that puts you in a
hypomanic state whether it's organic
mania whether it's stimulants cocaine
amphetamine use it feels good for a
while and you're going to feel like i'm
on top of the world and i can do all
these things and nothing can stop me
your reduced need for sleep
quickly will turn your brain to mush and
also induce psychosis like you just
can't take amphetamines
on an increasing basis or like if you're
prescribed adderall you take the same
amount every day that's fine but if
you're like if you give the average
person a pile of amphetamines or you put
them on trend at this high of a dose
it doesn't take very long to for that to
start really interrupting your sleep and
that's when those problems happen that's
when you start to hallucinate right
that's when you start to get really
short-tempered because your executive
functions are compromised when you don't
have sleep so
you know i don't know if it's the
chicken or the egg with regards to
you know does trend itself make you this
roid-raging [ __ ] or is it preventing
you from sleeping
which turns anyone into an [ __ ] at
least it's you know those are all
related things so i'm just saying i'm
gonna do this for a week and then not do
it and i just wouldn't recommend
doing these high doses on a long-term
basis if
for nothing else just the fact that it
interrupts your sleep and that's so
important and
bad things can happen when you're a guy
who's not getting sleep and also full of
androgens that make you aggressive and i
will say this
in response to minor frustrations i'll
have fantasies of violence now where
it's like something happened i'm like i
want to kick that person i don't do it
but it's like that flash in your head
you know like i could solve this by
hitting that person i don't do it but
like
if you're not emotionally mature enough
to handle those situations because of
course like most men have those rushes
of like i want to respond like this
and the first time i did trent actually
in college i remember getting in a fight
that was totally avoidable but i just
like wanted to hit this guy who was
acting like a dick but i could have
avoided it
and uh you know i hit him and broke my
hand cool
um not cool at all because that's just a
very very minor exact could have gone to
jail it's a very minor example of you
know these these impulsive decisions
that you make that are high progressive
that can have real world consequences
like the doctor is telling me not to
lift he's like we're gonna put a cast on
i'm like no no i have football you know
i'm gonna be lifting all summer so i
like didn't put a cast on my broken hand
so i could continue to lift the ultimate
meathead move took tren
beat somebody up didn't listen to the
doctor kept lifting weights mark harley
in a nutshell
all right is there other cool stuff i
saw on the internet this week let me
think so
there's a link right above the fat kid
there we go hidden in there
oh did you see this video
he says he can't face it not yet so this
guy put something like he put a speaker
or something big in there and his little
hatchback and it was just big enough
that like the angle of the hatchback hit
the thing the corner of the thing that
he's putting in there so he slams it
down and the window breaks and he just
immediately has to look away
and i just related to that so much
because things will happen sometimes
where it's like you just spill like a
whole plate of food or dump something
and you know it's like oh my god this is
such a huge mess like i just
[ __ ] myself over for no reason but i
just i need 10 seconds i can't look at
it like i just i'm going to pretend like
nothing happened for a minute to gather
myself and calm down and that it's like
this is just a perfect execution of that
and
yeah he puts his hands in his hoodie
he's like yeah right the most like this
isn't this didn't just this is yeah this
isn't happening no this is this is uh no
but pretend like uh that was just i'm
chill it's a dream yeah it's totally
chilly and somebody was like i don't
think he so i show this somebody like
did he notice it
and i'm like oh he noticed it because
what he does is this little
look at it he goes
but i like that because he collects
himself he doesn't hit me in the face
like i did at 22 years old
on trend and uh he keeps it moving and
figures out what he's gonna do
with his broken hatchback window okay a
lot of people been asking me really cool
stuff
because i'm an authority on so many
different things
this was a you know i think i've
answered this question like generally
before but i wanted to touch on it again
hey mark
i had a question that i'm sure you'll
have an answer to i like that confidence
in me
he's sure he's positive we'll have an
answer for him what do you do to
mentally get past a less than ideal
workout and this guy's james mauldin by
the way
um
i find every now and then when i leave
the gym and didn't meet my expectation
for that particular session that it kind
of eats at me
a little bit do you have any potentially
helpful advice in that area so
i almost hesitated to do this segment
because i'm like does this sound
repetitive because i kind of give this
same message a lot but i thought it was
worth artic he didn't know what my
message was in this so i feel like okay
well
if he pays attention to me and he's not
he doesn't feel like i'm gonna be
repeating myself let's go for it good
question i tried to find something that
was worthwhile i give myself credit for
showing up that is huge
because at minimum you're giving your
muscles a reason to not shrink
you're burning calories you're sticking
to a routine you're doing something
that's healthier and more productive
than not showing up and when i say
giving your muscles a reason not to
shrink that's like if you go up and do a
heavy set of bench press that actually
is beneficial because
it it says you're about whoa let's not
go catabolic just yet whoa we still need
this because your body's always
evaluating your muscle mass like do we
need all this do you need to be 260 on
chick-fil-a and tren
but uh if you do a bare minimum
it is effective like your body if you
don't if you do nothing it's going to
shrink a lot faster you're going to lose
those gains compared to doing a minimum
amount of sets which could be just
literally one hard set of bench press or
a few sets of like eighty percent so
there's always something there and then
you're showing up and you're burning
calories you're doing something you're
getting your heart rate up a little bit
and all of that even just walking around
to the gym versus sitting even keeping
in that routine so that like i was
telling my brother this because he's
having a
this nagging back injury i'm like go
just show up and like lay on a yoga mat
for 10 minutes
because at least you're going at least
you're going i'm showing up and the
people at the front desk know me and
it's not going to be one of these weird
things like oh hey i haven't seen you in
three months and then you're ashamed and
then you don't want to come back like
build the rapport with these people and
build yourself in your own mind as
somebody who shows up to the gym
okay so it's more productive than not
showing up and more specifically
i use different ways to tell myself i
improved if i can't pr that day and
straight like weight total
i add a set or do something new do a new
exercise so that that immediately
becomes the pr because i've never done
that before add pause wraps do a drop
set
do a circuit you know instead of doing
all these things straight like combine
them in a you know 10 minute full body
circuit which
and and drop all the weight down to
something minimal but all of a sudden
you need to hit cardio circuit remind
myself that if the workout was less than
ideal because of physical limitations
like not being fully recovered
getting blood into the muscle is still
beneficial so these are all just mental
tricks that i go it was still worth it
it was still worth it it was still worth
it
i always say this too and i told this to
to warn last night if you get to the gym
five times and one of them or two of
those workouts were hard workouts you're
you're in
a
a surplus as far as making improvements
to your body right
you are winning if you get two hard
workouts a week or even one and the rest
of them we're half assed you're still
building the habit and that is so so so
important because over the long term you
want those 200 workouts in a year you
don't want the 30 workouts that burn you
out and you're trying to puke after
every single leg workout that's another
thing we talked about where it's like
you know
and he's a former competitive swimmer he
knows what it's like to push himself
and probably knows what it's like to
get to that point of so much lactic acid
coursing through your veins that
you do want to puke in the nearest trash
can but
instead you just suck it up keep that
speedo on
do another 200 butterfly
and think about killing yourself at a
later date
so
how a sick fitness page is
oh my goodness
we will go on to this guy william retell
dude's a beast i think he's the strength
and conditioning coach for
north dakota state if i'm not mistaken
i'm sorry if you're watching this and
that's not true but he is the head
strength and conditioning coach for what
i
understand
of a major uh ncaa team
and boy oh boy is he
living his uh his message because if you
go to his page you're just going to see
him
lifting heavy doing cleans dunking like
you know he's just
he's he's a white guy who looks like
he's like 250 probably i don't like he's
he's thick and he can dunk like with
ease and so you're just gonna see a lot
of workouts that you can do and he gives
these
um easy directives like if we click on
these things it's like squats and dunks
one prep for takeoff two take off so
here he is doing a safety bar squat with
like
455 it looks like and then he goes and
practices the dunking so he gives these
simple directives of like one two three
right let's click on another video
whatever it is um this one squats and
dunks get big legs get big bounce so you
kind of see him like
getting speed out of the bottom with
these reps and then practicing is done
now
this is a great page if you really want
to dunk but also it's anything because
he's he's showing you how the basics
translate
to these important athletic things
humongous horseshoes for your triceps
primary heavy dips secondary close grip
floor press tertiary lying extensions
and so that's a good basic format where
you take these
heavy compound movements and then you
work your way
to
these more isolated but still heavy as
you can see
what's that the lying extensions i've
never even seen that that looks
interesting yes yeah skull crushers and
he's doing a little he's bringing that
stretch in more because you can kind of
do a
there's a variety it's like if you take
a close grip bench press and then you
start to move it here
it like i think it's called like a jm
press or something but it's like these
are all you know what i mean it's like
varying difficulty
easiest this becomes a little bit harder
a little more triceps a little less
shoulders and and then all the way back
here what you're really doing is
stretching that long head you know so if
you bring it all the way back here and
it also becomes this kind of
almost explosive movement with your lats
too he's not really doing he's a little
bit yeah but that's like that's a good
athletic movement because that's like a
throwing movement now
but i just love
pages like this to take
these principles of building muscle for
a purpose for athleticism here he is
doing
heavy snatch like hang snatches you know
that looks i don't know what that is off
the top of my head um it might say there
but i'm guessing it's like
could be like 275 actually
just hang snatching that which is a lot
of weight um to just throw up over your
head while moving but check him out it's
will w-i-l-l dot retell r-a-t-e-l-l-e
you will learn something just by going
to his page and watching a few videos
especially if you're interested in
athletic performance and also he's got
um
a podcast
it's called barbell nerds i think yeah
that's what it is barbell nerds and he
also has a he has a book that you can
buy that would go into depth
on sets and reps and like because you
can watch these little videos and get
something out of it if you want to take
his program
uh it's called the haas project so if
you're looking to get big and also be
athletic go buy this program these guys
are good faith actors like dudes like
this where it's like they're not trying
to rip you off they're showing you i do
the basics i do them really well and
that leads to me being able to dunk on
these fools
okay
why don't we
finish up
with some this is why we can't have nice
gyms because this is why we can't have
nice gyms this is a guy i feel bad for
picking on him but at the same time
every time i'm in the gym he's doing the
most ridiculous stuff he's doing the the
spider-man like taking the whole cable
stack and i was talking about this with
another guy who goes to the gym with me
he's like oh have you seen this guy he
always does that like because he just
takes up so much space and it's
obnoxious now i did my secret
recording of him i'm always so
self-conscious and i feel bad but at the
same time he doesn't watch my podcast so
whatever dude
he's doing like
what you would assume is an attempt at a
rear delt raise but he's using 70 pound
dumbbells and basically just swinging
and it's like i'm sorry but there's no
tension there and also if you could do
that with any sort of
correct form
with a 70 pound dumbbell
your rear delts would be huge like you
wouldn't look like this guy and i'm not
saying he's in terrible shape but at the
same time for all these like if you're
going to be going out of your way to
have these unconventional lifts like
be ripped be massive have something to
show the rest of the world
i'm not a complete maniac this actually
works
right now i'm seeing none of that and so
i just think it's funny and i will
continue to film this guy because this
is exactly what not to do and i want to
interview him and be like where did you
get the idea that instead of doing a 20
pound rear delt raise i need to
quadruple that weight
and get nothing out of it
this i thought was a funny little video
this guy goes uh
let's get it tricep rope what is this a
plan of fitness maybe who knows
uh
and he licks the weiner
i don't know if that was planned or what
maybe what but he pulls it off where
he's like he like legitimately looks
like he's looking for the other side of
the rope and then it's just like this
big black dong in his face and he just
like licks it like so mildly you know
like it's just a you know an automatic
response okay and we have one more we're
gonna end on this
this dude runs over the spot
i can't like we have to analyze this
because i'm going
there's so much going on in this video
the guy runs over slips on is that a
like a foam roller on the ground or no
it's the
it's those uh the pins that you put in
the squat rack right
no i can't even see what it is is it a
metal thing or is it a foam roller
but suffice to say he he runs over to
spot a guy who doesn't even look like
he's having trouble like the bar dips
for a second on his bench press but it
looked like it was traveling upwards so
don't run over and touch somebody's bar
that is traveling upwards but then
this guy goes and grabs it slips on the
thing his hand goes right to the dude's
dick
and destroys the entire lift like he now
is
shoving 315 pounds down on the guy's
upper chest to neck area another guy
comes over and tries to salvage it but
by then it's too late
so
people in the comments are like is this
real
and i'm like
if it isn't you guys are brilliant but
like how do you plan the slip on the
thing and fall to the like that looks
real to me casey what do you think i
think it's fake okay i think we landed i
think the speed with which he turns his
hands over and goes from i'm pulling
immediately to i'm pushing it it feels
it doesn't feel okay right that's a good
that's a good one reaction oh
right yeah yeah yeah because he does he
comes under first and then when he slips
all of a sudden he's pushing down you're
right that is a good point
my big issue is like
slipping is dangerous so unless you're
like a stunt guy well you are a stunt
guy so maybe you're looking at this
through the lens of like i could pull
that off but i'm looking at it like what
if you tear your acl doing this stupid
thing and then you're like oh yeah it
was a dick grabbing prank and now i
don't have an acl they could have
rehearsed it this could have been the
fifth take six take care but as soon as
his foot
touches like it's not even slipping yet
he turns this christian i want you to
chime in on this do you think it's real
or fake
i did see
i did see this too i mean
it
looks real but the way like
what confuses me is it looks real he
goes to stop himself like this and then
switches and throws them over so yeah so
like you see casey's point that it's a
little suspicious that the it is
where it goes
to save yourself yeah and also
after he falls
and crushes his boy yeah and he like
that guy's helping him try and bring the
weights up he's just staring at his boy
like damn yeah so right okay so and he
does push it down let's leave it to the
audience what do you think real or fake
drop it in the comments let's see who
wins we're gonna take a tally we're
gonna do the poll we're gonna come back
we're gonna circle back we're going to
put a pin in it and you know what else
we're going to put a pin in my body
because i'm taking 700 milligrams of
trend per week
i'm taking
1400 milligrams of winstrol per week i'm
taking 700
to 1400 milligrams i haven't even
decided on my master on dose okay i just
want to show you guys
okay i'm gonna get this out of here okay
this is for posterity's sake all right
we're just gonna do a little bit of
do i look bigger also comment there
do i look bigger
do i do i look do my legs look small
off camera do i look small
do i look insecure flexing for your
approval in the comments do i or not
let's start a gofundme and we can get
mark therapy sessions that he doesn't
have to be insecure about his
asymmetrical body parts okay
let's do it bye